It is an old, old story. A group of friends gets together, decides to start a business, put on a show, or begin their own church, or take a political stand, together, as a group. Hearts are full. Everyone's close. But over time, there's some small thing that comes up, some dispute. And the dispute starts small and takes on more importance, and more until it becomes the most important thing that any of them think about. Until it becomes the main thing that they all think about. And until it destroys the group.
这是一个非常古老的故事。一群朋友聚在一起，决定一起创业、演出、建立教会，或者共同表达某种政治立场，大家齐心协力。大家意气相投，亲密无间。但随着时间推移，出现了一些琐事，产生了一些分歧。分歧开始时很小，却变得越来越重要，直到它成了他们每个人心中最重要的事情。直到它成了他们所有人共同关心的核心。直到它最终摧毁了这个团体。
Well, it is This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. The premise of our program is that each week we document everyday stories of these United States, using all the tools of radio storytelling-- documentaries, monologues, overheard conversations, found tapes, occasional radio dramas, anything we can think of. And today we bring you three stories of friends coming together to do some kind of project or work together, friends who end up as enemies.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目的宗旨是每周记录美国日常生活中的故事，使用广播叙事的所有手法——纪录片、独白、偶然听到的对话、现成的录音、偶尔的广播剧，任何我们能想到的形式。今天，我们为您带来三个关于朋友们聚在一起共同进行某种项目或工作，最终却反目成仇的故事。
Act One is about a religious group, Act Two about a political group, and Act Three about a racial group. Stay with us.
第一幕关于一个宗教团体，第二幕关于一个政治团体，第三幕关于一个种族团体。请继续收听。
Act One, Saints of the Last Days.
第一幕：末世圣徒。
Our first story today takes place in Utah, home of the Mormon church, which, out there, they sometimes called the LDS church. LDS for Latter Day Saints.
我们今天的第一则故事发生在犹他州，那里是摩门教会的大本营，当地人有时称其为LDS教会。LDS指“后期圣徒”（Latter Day Saints）。
Joseph Smith and Brigham Young received visions when they founded the church and established it there. And to this day, it is not uncommon for Mormons to see visions and to set up their own variations on the main LDS church.
约瑟·斯密（Joseph Smith）和杨百翰（Brigham Young）在创立该教会并在此定居时曾收到过异象。直到今天，摩门教徒看到异象并建立起各自不同于主流LDS教会的教派，也并不罕见。
Scott Carrier has the story of one such splinter church, how friends began it and how the friends over time, split apart.
斯科特·卡里尔（Scott Carrier）讲述了这样一个分裂教会的故事，讲述了朋友们如何开始，又如何随着时间推移分道扬镳。
This is a story about a group of radical Mormon polygamists who live in central Utah in a little town called Manti. I call them radical because they've all been excommunicated by the church authorities, not for practicing polygamy, not because they were sinners. They were excommunicated because they said over and over again that the church authorities were working for Satan.
这是一个关于一群激进摩门教一夫多妻主义者的故事，他们住在犹他州中部一个叫曼泰（Manti）的小镇。我称他们为激进分子，是因为他们都被教会当局开除了，不是因为实行一夫多妻制，也不是因为他们是罪人。他们被开除是因为他们反复说教会当局是在为撒旦工作。
I'll begin this story by introducing Jim Harmston, a middle-aged man of common qualities, a man who used to sell real estate up in Davis County. He was a Mormon, a good Mormon, a member of the high council. He had a house on the hill and a new Continental every six months.
我先介绍一下吉姆·哈姆斯顿（Jim Harmston），一个有着普通特质的中年男子，曾经在戴维斯县（Davis County）卖房地产。他曾经是一名摩门教徒，虔诚的摩门教徒，高级理事会成员。他曾在山上拥有房产，每六个月就换一辆新的大陆牌轿车。
But then, in 1990, he started to believe that the church had become wicked in the eyes of the Lord, and he started praying in the true order, and seeing angels, and receiving divine messages from across the veil who told him first that he should quit his job and move with his family to Manti, which he did. Next, to become a polygamist, which he did. And then, to become the prophet and president of his own new church, the True and Living Church of Jesus Christ of Saints of the Last Days, which he also did.
但在1990年，他开始相信教会在上帝眼中已经堕落，他开始按照“真秩序”祈祷，看见天使，并从帷幕彼岸收到神圣的信息，告诉他首先应该辞职，带着家人搬到曼泰，他照做了。接下来，要成为一夫多妻主义者，他也照做了。然后，成为他自己新教会的先知和主席，即“耶稣基督后期圣徒真活教会”（True and Living Church of Jesus Christ of Saints of the Last Days），他也照做了。
He did, in effect, have very nearly the same experience that Joseph Smith had 160 years before.
实际上，他经历的几乎和160年前约瑟·斯密所经历的一模一样。
I had an experience where four dispensation heads came across the veil and laid their hands on my head-- Enoch, Noah, Abraham, and Moses-- restoring again the apostleship. And this happened on a Sunday. They were magnificent resurrected beings clothed in white garment, white clothing, to their robes hung to their ankles. They had white hair and beards. They were magnificent, and I was overwhelmed with the Holy Ghost. And it's been interesting to observe. People give up their careers and their professions, their businesses, and begin to gather here in Manti.
我经历过一次，四位福音时代的领袖从帷幕彼岸走来，按手在我的头上——以诺、挪亚、亚伯拉罕和摩西——恢复了使徒职位。这发生在星期天。他们是宏伟的复活灵体，身穿白袍，衣服垂到脚踝。他们有白色的头发和胡须。他们非常壮观，我被圣灵深深震撼了。观察这一切很有趣，人们放弃了他们的职业、生意，开始聚集到曼泰来。
On Sunday afternoon, Harmston's church has a testimonial meeting. 150 men, women, and children on folding chairs in a newly constructed meeting hall. Testimony meeting is a Mormon tradition where members stand and bear their testimony in the truth and validity of the church and its doctrines. But many of the people here have recently been excommunicated, and so their testimony is that the Mormon church has become corrupt. Indeed, that this congregation now is the only true and living church on the planet.
周日下午，哈姆斯顿的教会有见证会。150名男女老少坐在新盖的会议大厅的折叠椅上。见证会是摩门教的传统，成员们站起来分享对教会及其教义的真实性和有效性的见证。但这里许多人最近刚被开除，所以他们的见证是摩门教已经腐败了。事实上，这个会众现在是地球上唯一真正活着的教会。
You know, I've been searching for a witness of this work and of this church. And just tonight I got my witness. And it's burning within my soul at how important this work is and how true it is. I know it is. And it's hard to believe that just a year ago I was in high school. I was in plays. I was a typical teenager. And now I'm in a plural marriage and struggling. I'm not going to lie to you.
你知道，我一直在寻找这项事工和这个教会的见证。就在今晚，我得到了我的见证。它在我灵魂深处燃烧，这项工作是多么重要，它是多么真实。我知道它是真的。很难相信就在一年前，我还在上高中。我还在演戏。我曾经是个典型的青少年。而现在，我处于多元婚姻中，并且在挣扎。我不会对你们撒谎。
Welcome to the club.
欢迎来到这个俱乐部。
But I know without a shadow of doubt that this is the Lord's work, that I have finally found it. And I love you guys, and I'm thankful for your prayers and for all that you have to offer me. I say this in the name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
但我毫无疑问地知道，这就是上帝的工作，我终于找到了它。我爱你们，感谢你们的祈祷和你们所能提供的一切。我以耶稣基督的名义说这些话。阿门。
Members of Harmston's church practice the principle of plural marriage because they believe polygamy was one of the fundamental teachings of Joseph Smith. This is why polygamists often refer to themselves as fundamentalists.
哈姆斯顿教会的成员实行多元婚姻原则，因为他们相信一夫多妻制是约瑟·斯密的基本教义之一。这就是为什么一夫多妻主义者经常自称为原教旨主义者。
They also believe in practicing the law of consecration, wherein all goods and services are held in common, a communism, and that there will be a gathering of God's chosen people into a nation, a Zion nation. This gathering is to be in a safe spot, an area protected during the Millennium and the Armageddon. It's all there in the Book of Revelations, and it's all happening now. Hundreds, some say thousands, of fundamentalists from around the West have moved to Manti over the past three years, all believing that this is the place for the gathering.
他们还相信实行“奉献律法”，即所有商品和服务公有，一种共产主义，并且上帝选民将聚集成为一个国家，一个锡安国（Zion nation）。这个聚集地将是一个安全的地方，在千禧年和哈米吉多顿战争期间受到保护。这一切都在《启示录》中，而且现在正在发生。在过去的三年里，数百甚至数千名来自西部各地的原教旨主义者搬到了曼泰，都相信这就是聚集之地。
Steve McKinley has lived in Manti for 15 years.
史蒂夫·麦金利（Steve McKinley）在曼泰住了15年。
This is a very special place. There have been very sacred things happen here. And I moved here to Manti 15 years ago because the Lord told us to move here. I've seen a lot of people come and go from this valley for spiritual reasons that are totally different. They didn't even know who Jim Harmston is. And they come, and they go.
这是一个非常特别的地方。这里发生过非常神圣的事情。我15年前搬到曼泰，因为上帝告诉我们要搬到这里。我看到很多人因为各种完全不同的精神原因来到这个山谷，又离开。他们甚至不知道吉姆·哈姆斯顿是谁。他们来了，又走了。
Steve McKinley and Jim Harmston used to be friends, but now they're more like enemies. They met when Harmston moved to Manti in 1990, and so McKinley has seen the development of Harmston's church from its beginning. It began as nothing more than a group of men from the Manti area who came together once a week and sat in a circle in an upstairs bedroom.
史蒂夫·麦金利和吉姆·哈姆斯顿曾经是朋友，但现在他们更像是敌人。他们是在1990年哈姆斯顿搬到曼泰时认识的，所以麦金利目睹了哈姆斯顿教会从起步到发展的全过程。它最初只是曼泰地区的一群男人，他们每周聚在一起，坐在楼上卧室的一个圆圈里。
There were 17 men who came together because they were concerned about things that were being taught and accepted by people as doctrine. And we were concerned, and we came together. And we prayed, and we asked, Heavenly Father, will you teach us? Will you tell us what is your doctrine and what is not? And will you protect us as individuals against things that we might do that would destroy ourselves?
有17个人聚在一起，因为他们关心人们正在教导和接受的教义。我们很担忧，于是聚在一起。我们祈祷，我们问天父，您能教导我们吗？您能告诉我们什么是您的教义，什么不是吗？您能保护我们个人免受可能摧毁我们自己的行为吗？
The other thing, if Randy needs a lump of coal to keep his family warm and Steve's got two, then Steve says, Randy, here, have one of my lumps of coal. And let's take care of each other. Let's help each other, because we love each other, and we're concerned.
另一件事是，如果兰迪（Randy）需要一块煤来给家人取暖，而史蒂夫有两块，史蒂夫就会说，兰迪，给你，拿去一块。让我们互相照顾。让我们互相帮助，因为我们彼此相爱，我们关心对方。
So there were two reasons that we came together-- to pray together and to help each other with our temporal needs.
所以我们聚在一起有两个原因——一起祈祷和在世俗需求上互相帮助。
They also did a lot of talking about the evils of the new world order, perhaps the need to stockpile weapons, the necessity of taking the kids out of the public schools, various conspiracies, secret combinations, and so on. The men held the meetings in each other's homes. And on special occasions, they'd set up a tepee on top of a mountain.
他们还谈论了很多关于“世界新秩序”的邪恶、也许需要储备武器的必要性、把孩子从公立学校接回来的必要性，以及各种阴谋、秘密组合等等。男人们在彼此家中聚会。在特殊场合，他们会在山顶搭起帐篷。
In the tepee, they'd sit in a circle and bear their testimony and pray in the true order, which is a secret Mormon ritual that's supposed to be performed only in a temple.
在帐篷里，他们围成一圈，作见证并按照“真秩序”祈祷，这是一种据说只能在圣殿中进行的秘密摩门教仪式。
Mormons believe that by praying in the true order, the veil that separates heaven and earth can be parted, enabling angels and messengers of the Lord to cross over into this temporal plane. Which is exactly what the men say started to happen in the tepee.
摩门教徒相信，通过按照真秩序祈祷，隔开天堂与地球的帷幕可以被揭开，使天使和上帝的使者能够跨越到这个世俗层面。这正是男人们所说的在帐篷里开始发生的事情。
They say their prayers called down lightning and thunderstorms from heaven. They say that this is where God first told the group to organize themselves along Iroquois guidelines, wherein all decisions were to be made by unanimous revelation. Not just unanimous consent, unanimous revelation, where everyone would pray and have a vision, the same vision, at the same time.
他们说他们的祈祷从天空中召唤出了闪电和雷暴。他们说，上帝就是在这里第一次告诉这个团体按照易洛魁人的准则来组织自己，即所有的决定都必须通过一致的启示来做出。不仅仅是一致同意，是一致的启示，即每个人都会祈祷，并在同一时间有同一个异象。
Then they all received a vision that they should give each other titles like war chief and peace chief and medicine chief and historian so that every man would be a chief with certain responsibilities, but that no man would be the ultimate chief with control over all the others.
然后他们都得到了一个异象，即应该给彼此起头衔，如战争酋长、和平酋长、医学酋长和历史学家，这样每个人都是拥有特定责任的酋长，但没有人是拥有控制所有其他人权力的最终酋长。
I recall the testimony meeting. And Jim Harmston stood up and he said, if any man here were to stand and declare himself a leader amongst these men, there would be 10 men who would stand up and shoot him in the knee caps, because none of us independently are the leader. We are a group of individuals who have come together, and nobody has authority over anybody else. That's how it started. That's how God called us together.
我记得那次见证会。吉姆·哈姆斯顿站起来说，如果这里有任何人站出来宣布自己是这些人之中的领袖，会有10个人站起来射击他的膝盖，因为我们之中没有哪个人能独立成为领袖。我们是一群聚在一起的个体，没有人对任何人拥有权力。这就是它是如何开始的。这就是上帝召集我们的方式。
The men started calling themselves the high council and then realized by unanimous revelation that they were actually new apostles of the Lord and that they should begin an entirely new church, the True and Living Church of Jesus Christ of Saints of the Last Days and that they should start confirming each other as members.
这些人开始自称为“高级理事会”，然后通过一致的启示意识到他们实际上是上帝的新使徒，他们应该开始一个全新的教会，即“耶稣基督后期圣徒真活教会”，并且他们应该开始互相确认对方的成员身份。
And so I asked Jim if he would confirm me. And as I sat in the chair facing the wall-- not the window, but the wall in Bart's living room--
所以我问吉姆是否愿意确认我。当我坐在椅子上对着墙时——不是对着窗户，而是对着巴特（Bart）客厅里的那堵墙——
Facing east.
面向东方。
Facing east. I had my head bowed, and my eyes were closed. And when I opened my eyes and was wondering why he was pausing. And then I closed my eyes again and I saw three men walk through the wall.
面向东方。我低着头，闭着眼睛。当我睁开眼睛，纳闷他为什么停顿时。我又闭上眼睛，看到三个人穿过墙壁。
It was Joseph Smith and Brigham Young and Heber C. Kimball who came through the veil. And they placed their hands upon my head and revealed many things concerning my life and my [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to certain things upon this earth that I should do. And I could see the vision as he spoke. I could see it, and Jim described what he saw, what we both saw in vision. And Jim was so overwhelmed, he closed the vision. Because he was so overwhelmed he could not continue the vision, Jim ended it. But it continued for me. And I saw many things that Jim did not speak.
那是约瑟·斯密、杨百翰和赫伯·C·金博尔（Heber C. Kimball）穿过了帷幕。他们按手在我的头上，启示了关于我生命的许多事情，以及我对地球上应该做的某些事情的[听不清]。当他说话时，我能看到异象。我能看到它，吉姆描述了他所看到的，我们俩在异象中都看到了。吉姆太激动了，他结束了异象。因为他太激动了，无法继续，吉姆结束了它。但它对我来说还在继续。我看到了许多吉姆没有说出来的事情。
The first major conflict within the new church came early on. One of the high council apostles, Randy Dalton, the historian, came to a meeting and presented a teaching on polygamy he called "Hearts and Flowers."
新教会内部的第一个重大冲突很早就出现了。高级理事会使徒之一、历史学家兰迪·道尔顿（Randy Dalton），来到一个会议，提出了一个他称为“心与花”（Hearts and Flowers）的一夫多妻教义。
I have a firm testimony that we are to become perfect. The Lord has commanded us, be, therefore, perfect, even as I or my father in heaven are perfect. Well, what does that mean? In the Greek and in the Hebrew, the word that is used that we translate as perfect really means to be whole or complete. I do not believe that it is possible for us to become whole or complete through intimate relationship with only one other person.
我坚定地见证我们应该变得完美。主命令我们，你们要完全，像你们的天父完全一样。好吧，那是什么意思？在希腊语和希伯来语中，我们翻译为“完美”的词，实际上意味着完整或齐全。我不认为我们通过与另一个人的亲密关系就能变得完整或齐全，这是可能的。
Now, the fact of the matter is that men just do not form emotionally intimate relationships with other men. It's really kind of foreign to our being. And yet, look at women. They have these incredibly emotionally intimate relationships. They know everything about each other. The empathy is incredibly. They feel what the other is feeling. And there is, in fact, one of the problems that is fundamental to most marriages, is that a woman craves a kind of nurturing in her relationship, in her marriage, that men are rarely capacitated to give. We're just not the nurturing types. And yet, a woman needs that. And as men, we just tend not to be able to give it.
事实是，男人确实无法与其他男人形成情感上的亲密关系。这对我们来说是很陌生的。然而，看看女人。她们有这些令人难以置信的情感亲密关系。她们了解对方的一切。同理心非常惊人。她们能感受到对方的感受。事实上，大多数婚姻的一个基本问题是，女人渴望在关系、婚姻中得到一种男人很少有能力给予的滋养。我们就是不是那种擅长滋养的类型。然而，女人需要那种滋养。作为男人，我们往往无法给予。
And yet, a sister wife can give so much of that emotional support that as men, we're just not very good at doing. And it can work very beautifully if you can get over issues like jealousy and things like that that get in the way. So I was talking about these kinds of things.
然而，姐妹妻子可以提供很多作为男人我们不太擅长的情感支持。如果能克服嫉妒之类的问题，它可以运作得非常美妙。所以我当时在谈论这些事情。
We thought he was talking about homosexuality, and we were going to go out there and rip his head off. We were upset because we didn't understand. We thought, is he talking about homosexuality? If he is, we're going to set this boy straight. We're going to explain some things to him. And Randy says, wait a minute, guys. That isn't what I said. You see, let me tell you.
我们以为他在谈论同性恋，我们打算冲出去把他撕碎。我们很不安，因为我们不明白。我们心想，他在谈论同性恋吗？如果他在谈论，我们要纠正这个男孩。我们要向他解释一些事情。而兰迪说，等等，伙计们。我不是那个意思。你看，让我告诉你。
And so we talked about it for a long time. And that's not what Randy was talking about. But we misunderstood it, and so did a lot of others. A lot of others thought that's what he was talking about. That was not it.
所以我们谈了很久。那不是兰迪谈论的内容。但我们误解了它，其他人也一样。许多人以为他是在谈论那个。那根本不是。
It was a teaching that grew into an argument, that grew into a conflict that couldn't be resolved. The question wasn't whether polygamy was OK. Everyone agreed that it was. The question was about sex, whether a polygamist man could have more than one of his wives in bed at a time.
这是一个演变成争论的教义，又演变成了一个无法解决的冲突。问题不在于一夫多妻制是否可以。每个人都同意是可以的。问题在于性，即一个一夫多妻制的男人是否可以同时在床上拥有不止一个妻子。
For two weeks, the group met and prayed in the true order. Some said it was an abomination. Others weren't so sure.
两周来，这个团体聚在一起，按照真秩序祈祷。有些人说这是可憎的事。其他人则不确定。
I told you earlier that many of us experimented with different things. The true order prayer, we experimented with a lot of things. I think that Joseph Smith was the greatest example of an experimenter. He experimented with a lot of things. He had seer stones and peep stones and witching rods to witch wells and water and all kinds of things. He experimented. He tested. There were many of us who tried and tested this so-called understanding of our sexuality with our wives. Many of us on both sides.
我之前告诉过你们，我们许多人尝试了不同的事情。真秩序祈祷，我们尝试了很多东西。我认为约瑟·斯密是实验者最伟大的典范。他尝试了很多事情。他有先见之石、窥视石、寻水杖等等。他尝试过。他测试过。我们许多人尝试并测试了这种所谓的与妻子性关系的理解。我们双方都有很多人。
Members of Jim's church, members of the quorum of the 12 apostles, members of the first presidency of Jim's church who participated and experimented with having sex with more than one wife in the bed at a time. They experimented with it, and they're OK. They're members of Jim's church.
吉姆教会的成员，12使徒定额组的成员，吉姆教会第一主席团的成员，他们参与并尝试过同时与一个以上的妻子发生性关系。他们尝试过，而且他们觉得没问题。他们是吉姆教会的成员。
Three weeks after Randy Dalton gave the "Hearts and Flowers" teaching, there was still considerable tension within the council. And at the next meeting, it split apart.
兰迪·道尔顿发表“心与花”教义三周后，理事会内部仍然存在相当大的紧张气氛。在下一次会议上，它分裂了。
Instead of the council talking it out and coming to unanimous revelation, Jim Harmston stood up and said he had received revelation for everyone that three in a bed was an abomination in the eyes of the Lord. And while he was at it, he said he also received revelation that he alone was now in charge of the church.
理事会没有讨论并达成一致的启示，吉姆·哈姆斯顿站起来说，他已经为每个人得到了启示，三人同床在主眼中是可憎的。当他在说这些时，他还说他得到了启示，现在由他独自掌管教会。
He stands, and he says, I have received revelation for these people. Thus sayeth the Lord. And I want to emphasize that. He said, thus sayeth the Lord.
他站起来，说，我已经为这些人得到了启示。耶和华如此说。我想强调这一点。他说，耶和华如此说。
Then Harmston and four other men stood and walked out of the meeting, leaving the others as outcasts, ostracized from the True and Living Church just as they had been ostracized from the Mormon church before.
然后哈姆斯顿和其他四个人站起来走出了会议，留下了其他人作为被驱逐者，被逐出“真活教会”，就像他们之前被逐出摩门教会一样。
At that moment, Jim Harmston placed himself in a position above the others. At that moment, Jim Harmston took control of the church.
在那一刻，吉姆·哈姆斯顿把自己置于了其他人之上。在那一刻，吉姆·哈姆斯顿控制了教会。
The sex thing was a smokescreen. It was a smokescreen to cover up Jim's ambition to take over the council and the nation and everything else. And what more better tool could he use than something that was disgusting to most people.
性这件事是个烟幕弹。这只是个掩盖吉姆接管理事会、国家和一切野心的烟幕弹。还有什么工具比大多数人觉得恶心的东西更好用呢？
If he could say, well, these guys are perverts. They're having orgies. They got everybody in bed, and they're a sex-crazed people. Well, if anybody believes that plural marriage is about sex, they got another thing coming. It has nothing to do with sex. It's about a relationship between people.
如果他能说，这些人是变态。他们搞淫乱。他们把所有人都弄到床上，他们是一群被性冲昏头脑的人。好吧，如果有人认为多元婚姻是关于性的，那他们就想错了。它与性无关。它是关于人与人之间的关系。
And God.
和上帝。
And God. It has nothing to do, very little to do with sex. Believe me, I know.
和上帝。它与性几乎无关。相信我，我知道。
But you know, Nietzsche made a very interesting comment. He said, "Battle not with monsters, lest you become a monster. And when you gaze into the abyss, the abyss is within you." And I think that's what happened is that Jim Harmston has spent so much time fighting against the LDS church that he's become a general authority. It may well be that every abuse he has accused the LDS church of may yet be found in his own circle.
但是，你知道，尼采发表过一个非常有趣的评论。他说：“与怪物战斗时，小心不要让自己变成怪物。当你凝视深渊时，深渊也在凝视你。”我认为发生的就是这样，吉姆·哈姆斯顿花太多时间与LDS教会斗争，以至于他自己变成了一个“总权威”。他指控LDS教会的每一种滥权行为，很可能都会在他自己的圈子里重演。
This split in the True and Living Church happened three years ago, and since then, Harmston has baptized hundreds of new members, whereas McKinley and Dalton and the others who were ostracized have pretty much just kept meeting with each other, four or five families getting together, sometimes on Sunday afternoons.
“真活教会”的这次分裂发生在三年前，从那以后，哈姆斯顿受洗了数百名新成员，而麦金利、道尔顿和其他被驱逐的人基本只是继续保持联系，四五个家庭聚在一起，有时在周日下午。
It was at one of these Sunday meetings that I interviewed McKinley and Dalton. And the scene in the house was very different from what it was like at the Harmston's. McKinley and Dalton and the others joked around and laughed a lot. Their wives talked loudly in the kitchen, and all ages of children were running around inside and out.
正是在这些周日聚会之一，我采访了麦金利和道尔顿。房子里的场景与哈姆斯顿家完全不同。麦金利和道尔顿等人开着玩笑，笑声不断。他们的妻子在厨房里大声交谈，各个年龄段的孩子在室内室外跑来跑去。
Occasionally, one of the wives would come into the living room where we were talking, and it was difficult to tell which man was her husband, they all got along so well. But at Harmston's house, his two wives were upset and not talking to each other. The first wife told me she'd gone after Jim that morning with a frying pan. The second wife hid in the back room. And there were no kids. Everything was quiet and serious. It was like going from interviewing a group of hippies to interviewing Richard Nixon.
偶尔，其中一位妻子会走进我们谈话的客厅，很难看出哪个男人是她的丈夫，他们相处得非常好。但在哈姆斯顿家，他的两个妻子很不高兴，互不说话。大老婆告诉我，那天早上她拿着平底锅去找吉姆算账。二老婆躲在后面的房间里。而且没有孩子。一切都安静而严肃。这就像从采访一群嬉皮士转变成采访理查德·尼克松。
Harmston sat at his desk in his study, looking out the window at the Manti Temple just a couple of blocks away, a temple built by the Mormon church over 80 years ago, a temple he still considers to be sacred and holy. But it's a temple he's no longer allowed to enter.
哈姆斯顿坐在书房的桌前，看着窗外的曼泰圣殿，那里距离只有几个街区，那是摩门教会在80多年前建造的圣殿，他仍然认为它是神圣的。但他现在已经不允许进入那座圣殿了。
He was kicked out of the Mormon church. He kicked out his friends from his own church. His closest allies now are the angels and spirits who promise him that he alone holds the keys to the kingdom of heaven.
他被赶出了摩门教会。他赶走了自己教会的朋友。他现在最亲密的盟友是那些向他保证他独自掌握着通往天国钥匙的天使和灵体。
Well, I'm either completely nuts or right on target, one or the other. And there isn't anything in between. They have to judge for themselves.
好吧，要么是我完全疯了，要么我完全正确，二者必居其一。中间没有别的选择。他们必须自己判断。
Saints of the Last Days was produced and reported by Scott Carrier with help from [? Caroline Campbell ?], Alex Caldiero, and myself.
《末世圣徒》由斯科特·卡里尔制作和报道，卡罗琳·坎贝尔（Caroline Campbell）、亚历克斯·卡尔迪罗（Alex Caldiero）和我本人协助。
[MUSIC - "CAIN AND ABEL"BY LOUIS ARMSTRONG]
[音乐 - 路易斯·阿姆斯特朗演唱的《该隐与亚伯》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Act Two, Political Faction.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。第二幕，政治派系。
Well, if you read the first books of the Bible, as the story of the Israelites coming together as a people, it doesn't take long. It does not take long before some Israelites are casting others out as undesirable. Just two generations after God makes the deal with Abraham to create a great nation, Joseph's brothers decide they're in and Joseph's out. Soon he's sold into slavery. Not long after, in biblical terms anyway, when the Israelites are in the desert fleeing Egypt, factions are doubting Moses' ability to lead them. They make the golden calf. There's another faction in the Book of Numbers. It happens a lot.
嗯，如果你读过《圣经》的前几本书，关于以色列人作为一个民族聚集在一起的故事，并不需要太久。没过多久，一些以色列人就把其他人当作不可接受的人驱逐出境。上帝与亚伯拉罕达成协议创造一个伟大民族仅两代人之后，约瑟的兄弟们就决定接纳一部分人，排挤约瑟。很快，他就被卖为奴隶。没过多久，在圣经术语中，当以色列人在沙漠中逃离埃及，派系就开始怀疑摩西领导他们的能力。他们铸造了金牛犊。《民数记》中还有另一个派系。这种情况经常发生。
Well, this next story takes place mostly in the mid 1970s, entirely among great believers, political believers in this case. And they're believers who had great ideals as well. And the ideals were not only about political matters, international and national affairs. They were very idealistic about how to treat each other. They made all decisions by consensus. They told the truth to each other. They believed that there was great value in being able to hear the truth and speak  the truth to each other about how things were going, and they still split apart, painfully.
好吧，接下来的这个故事主要发生在1970年代中期，完全发生在一群坚定的信徒中间，在这里是政治信徒。他们也是拥有伟大理想的信徒。这些理想不仅关于政治问题、国际和国内事务。他们对于如何对待彼此也非常理想主义。他们通过协商做出所有决定。他们对彼此说真话。他们相信能够听到真相并对彼此说出事情的进展情况具有巨大价值，但他们仍然分崩离析，痛苦不堪。
Beau O'Reilly tells this story. He's a prolific local playwright, musician, performer. And we welcome him.
博·奥莱利（Beau O'Reilly）讲述了这个故事。他是一位多产的当地剧作家、音乐家、表演者。我们欢迎他。
I broke my own rules today. I slipped into the Water Tower Mall. And when I saw Betty Byzantine, I knew it was her right away, even though her whole physical aspect had changed quite a bit in the seven or eight years since I had last seen her.
我今天打破了自己的规则。我溜进了水塔购物中心。当我看到贝蒂·拜占庭（Betty Byzantine）时，我立刻认出了她，尽管她整个人在过去七八年里发生了很大的变化。
Her body in the old days was lumpy and full of itself. But it had gone all sculpted and molded, a '90s weight world training woman's center body now. Her hair, which had been a mossy color of brown was now hennaed red, and it was the red hennaed highlights that made her stand out on that escalator.
她过去的身材臃肿且自我膨胀。但现在她变得雕塑感十足，是那种90年代健身房训练出来的女性身体。她的头发，曾经是苔藓般的棕色，现在染成了指甲花红，正是这种红色的指甲花高光让她在扶梯上显得格外显眼。
She looked good, better than I looked. At least better than I felt that day. And I thought, well, better to leave old Betty Byzantine alone. We didn't part on the best of terms.
她看起来很好，比我看起来好多了。至少比我那天感觉到的要好。我想，好吧，最好别去打扰老贝蒂·拜占庭。我们分手时并不愉快。
And I thought she hadn't recognized me, but as the escalator reached the eighth floor and she got off, she turned and deliberately pointed one long finger, cold. Just that one finger and Betty Byzantine was gone.
我以为她没认出我，但当扶梯到达八楼，她走下来时，她转过身，故意用一根长长的手指指着我，冷冰冰的。就那一只手指，然后贝蒂·拜占庭就消失了。
Now, the terrible thing about Betty Byzantine was that there was really nothing terrible about her. She was more plain, I guess. That's a nice way to say it. She had tended to fade into the background and become one of the small facts of the day. There was nothing that really stood out about Betty Byzantine when I knew her.
现在，关于贝蒂·拜占庭最糟糕的事情是，她其实没什么糟糕的。我猜，用“朴实”来形容比较委婉。她倾向于淡出背景，成为一天中的一个小事实。当我认识她时，贝蒂·拜占庭身上没有任何突出的地方。
And I have examined my behavior towards Betty Byzantine occasionally over these last 15 years. Although I found myself wanting and insensitive towards her, even in my efforts to tell her story, I've never felt compelled to do anything to make it all right between us. I've never felt the latent Catholic urge to confess it all and to throw myself at her feet, beg forgiveness for my coldness in the past. This is another one of my rules I'm breaking. I tend to be very amends oriented.
在过去的15年里，我偶尔会审视自己对待贝蒂·拜占庭的行为。尽管我发现自己对她显得无能且麻木不仁，但即使在努力讲述她的故事时，我也从未感到有义务去弥补我们之间的一切。我从未感到那种天主教徒式的、想要忏悔一切并跪在她脚下乞求宽恕过去冷漠的潜意识冲动。这是我打破的另一条规则。我倾向于非常有弥补意识。
The first time I saw Betty Byzantine was in the kitchen of The Palace, our collectively run vegetarian restaurant and coffee house. And Betty Byzantine was covered in this finely ground whole wheat flour. She was desperately trying to force it into a pie crust shape.
我第一次见到贝蒂·拜占庭是在“宫殿”（The Palace）的厨房里，这是我们集体经营的素食餐厅和咖啡馆。贝蒂·拜占庭身上沾满了这种精磨的全麦面粉。她正拼命想把它揉成派皮的形状。
First pie crusts are unbearably a failure, and Betty's would prove no exception. She was working under the watchful eyes of Small Craig, who was in charge of all of our desserts and our volunteers. Pies and cakes and tarts, they were a lot of work, and Small Craig was always on the lookout for that rarest of individuals, the hardworking volunteer.
第一次做派皮总是注定失败，贝蒂的也不例外。她在小克雷格（Small Craig）的注视下工作，小克雷格负责我们所有的甜点和志愿者。派、蛋糕和挞，工作量很大，小克雷格总是在寻找那种最稀有的志愿者：勤劳的人。
Small Craig was the most amicable of the hippies that I knew. And yet, at the same time, he was a man of efficient and disciplined work habits. I could give Small Craig any job and consider it done. And we, the hippie family of The Palace collective, leaned on him.
小克雷格是我认识的嬉皮士中最友善的。然而，同时，他也是一个工作习惯高效且自律的人。我可以给小克雷格任何工作，并认定它能完成。而我们，“宫殿”集体这个嬉皮家庭，都很依赖他。
Betty Byzantine was a sniffler. She was sniffling now. And that sniffling would never stop the whole seven years I knew her. Betty Byzantine had allergies, the year-round variety. Allergies to dogs, milk, copper, dust, snow. And it was those allergies that brought her to our palace in the first place. We were, in 1974, an island of health in a world collapsing under fast foods. It was the allergies that brought her to The Palace where we hippies, 10 or 12 of us, lived and worked together.
贝蒂·拜占庭是个爱吸鼻子的人。她现在就在吸鼻子。在我认识她的七年里，这种吸鼻子的声音从未停止过。贝蒂·拜占庭有过敏症，是全年都有的那种。对狗、牛奶、铜、灰尘、雪过敏。正是这些过敏让她第一次来到我们的宫殿。1974年，在快餐业崩溃的世界里，我们是一个健康的孤岛。正是过敏让她来到“宫殿”，我们10到12个嬉皮士住在一起，工作在一起。
It was the allergies that brought her there, but it was Small Craig's eyes that kept her there, I think. She had eyes for Small Craig. And long after her hands had proven too clumsy for pie crusts, we were all still eating Betty Byzantine's pies. Forced to by Small Craig who believed such diligence must be rewarded by the rest of us. Our pie palates might suffer, Small Craig argued, but Betty Byzantine's satisfaction at seeing all of us chew on her ashen-tasting pies was well worth it.
是过敏让她来到这里，但我想，是小克雷格的目光让她留了下来。她对小克雷格有意思。即使在她的手被证明太笨拙而不适合做派皮很久之后，我们大家还在吃着贝蒂·拜占庭的派。是被小克雷格强迫吃的，他认为这种勤奋必须得到我们其他人的回报。小克雷格辩解说，我们的味蕾可能会受苦，但看到贝蒂·拜占庭看着我们咀嚼她那灰烬味道的派时所感到的满足，这一切都是值得的。
And two years later, after the collapse of The Palace under a mass of debt on debt, bad decisions leading to no decisions, we moved in smaller groups of three or four, hunting the great Midwest, the small college towns, for the last outposts of the hippie nation, which had spread and spewed itself like so much volcanic ash at the end of the Vietnam War and now flickered with a doubtful light. And the increasing draft of the '70s, that post-Nixon shame era, flickered with a still wild and a restless energy.
两年后，随着“宫殿”在债务、糟糕决策导致的无决策中崩溃，我们分成三四个人的小组，在中西部寻找小学院城，寻找“嬉皮国家”的最后据点，它像越战结束时的火山灰一样散布和喷射，现在闪烁着怀疑的光芒。70年代日益严重的征兵，那个后尼克松时代的羞耻时期，闪烁着一种依然狂野和躁动不安的能量。
Madison, Wisconsin, was one of those places. It was comfortably feminist, cooperative, organic. And Small Craig landed there, and I did too. And Betty Byzantine followed like a magnet in a ball bearing factory, showing up the same day Small Craig did. She just happened to be looking for an apartment in the same neighborhood. She just happened to need a roommate. Betty and Craig became roommates.
麦迪逊（Madison），威斯康星州，就是其中之一。那里舒适、女性主义、合作、有机。小克雷格到了那里，我也到了。而贝蒂·拜占庭像轴承厂里的磁铁一样紧随其后，和小克雷格同一天出现。她碰巧在同一个社区找公寓。她碰巧需要一个室友。贝蒂和克雷格成了室友。
Me, I had already started looking for the next big issue. The war had done a lot for the left. It had forced us into action. But what was next, nuclear weapons or that quiet nastier cousin, nuclear power?
我当时已经开始寻找下一个重大议题。战争为左翼做了很多贡献，它迫使我们采取行动。但接下来是什么呢？核武器，还是核武器那个安静而邪恶的表亲——核能？
Nuclear power had slowly replaced the faded war in our conversations, and it was all over our personal view screen that summer. There were activists' "let's do something about the power plants" edges to every political conversation I was having. And I quickly became impassioned and determined to take an activist stand. There were others around me feeling the same thing. So soon we had a new alternative family, the nuclear radioactivists we called ourselves.
那个夏天，核能已经在我们的谈话中缓慢取代了日渐褪色的战争话题，并充斥在我们的个人视野里。我参与的每一次政治对话中，总有激进分子在谈论“我们得针对核电站做点什么”。我很快变得热情高涨，决心采取激进立场。我周围其他人也有同感。于是，我们很快拥有了一个新的替代家庭，我们自称为“核放射激进分子”。
And I invited Small Craig along, and here came Betty Byzantine uninvited, but not unexpected. We picked a nuclear power plant that was doing terrible things in an increasingly obvious way. It was in a section of Illinois that was closest to our Madison home, so a justifiable move on our part. A stand could be made there. And after a series of late night rave-ups about it all and nonviolence training workshops, we went, and we made one. And this was us.
我邀请了小克雷格加入，接着贝蒂·拜占庭不请自来，不过也在意料之中。我们选定了一座正在以越来越明显的方式做着可怕之事的核电站。它位于伊利诺伊州离我们麦迪逊家最近的地方，所以对我们来说是一个合理的行动地点。我们可以在那里表明立场。在一系列关于此事的深夜狂欢和非暴力培训研讨会之后，我们出发了，并付诸了行动。这就是我们。
Mordecai, the crazed chemistry grad student who wanted to be a dancer, a filmmaker, or Allen Ginsberg but who carried this huge weight of serious chemistry all over his body and his shoulders. But he was the most naturally anarchistic one of all of us. He drove recklessly. He smoked too much. He dated all the women we knew.
莫迪凯，那个疯狂的化学系研究生，他想当舞者、电影制作人或是艾伦·金斯堡，但他身上背负着沉重的化学研究压力。但他却是我们中最崇尚无政府主义的人。他开车鲁莽，烟抽得太多，和我们认识的所有女性约会。
And there was Maggie, who we said would smile and hand you a hand grenade like it was a lovely piece of fruit. She would later become a New Yorker, a macrobiotic lesbian witch painter who crammed her canvases with live fish and dead fish bones. But back then she was clear as a bell, a real hippie girl.
还有玛吉，我们常说她会微笑着把一枚手榴弹递给你，就像递给你一块美味的水果。后来她成了纽约人，一个宏量饮食的女同性恋女巫画家，她的画布上塞满了活鱼和死鱼骨头。但那时她清醒如钟，是一个真正的嬉皮女孩。
And there was Teddy, who had this laugh like Bugs Bunny. Teddy was everybody's best friend and confidant. Teddy had a major flaw when it came to activism though. When it came time to be arrested, Teddy was out the door.
还有泰迪，他的笑声像兔八哥。泰迪是每个人的好朋友和知己。不过，泰迪在参与激进活动时有一个重大缺陷：一到该被捕的时候，泰迪准会溜之大吉。
There was Michelle. Michelle was a stalwart, a Quaker. She was well trained in nonviolence and consensus decision making. And she was the most radically left of all of us, first to be arrested and last to back down.
还有米歇尔。米歇尔是个忠实拥护者，一名贵格会教徒。她受过良好的非暴力和共识决策训练。她是我们要中最激进的左派，总是第一个被捕，也是最后一个退缩的。
There's Kirk. Kirk was beautiful, and he rode a 10-speed bicycle up and down the hills of Madison without ever touching the handle bars, reading Joseph Conrad or William Faulkner. Handsome Kirk was Stalwart Michelle's lover until Small Craig's eyes moved him into Michelle's heart. That change left Kirk quivering with emotion and Betty Byzantine just quivering. That was the core of my radioactivist family, and I was often our unofficial spokesperson. I was 27, usually barefoot, and my hair was down to my hips. Came from a poverty background with little education. I was weak on the facts, but fierce with emotion and so earnest in those days. Earnest with the cops, earnest with the plant workers, earnest with the judge.
还有柯克。柯克很帅，他骑着一辆十速自行车在麦迪逊的山丘上上下下，从不扶车把，一边骑还一边读约瑟夫·康拉德或威廉·福克纳的作品。英俊的柯克曾是忠诚的米歇尔的恋人，直到小克雷格的眼神让他走进了米歇尔的心里。那个改变让柯克情绪颤动，也让贝蒂·拜占庭颤动不已。那就是我的放射激进家庭的核心，我通常是我们非官方的发言人。我当时27岁，经常赤着脚，头发垂到臀部。我出身贫寒，受教育程度不高。我事实依据不足，但情感热烈，在那些日子里非常真诚。对警察真诚，对工厂工人真诚，对法官真诚。
That was the group of us that went into battle armed with good intentions and a not long for the real world glow of love for each other. And we blockaded that nuclear power plant.
这就是我们这群人，怀揣着美好的初衷和对彼此那份不长久的爱，奔赴战场。我们封锁了那座核电站。
Beau O'Reilly's story continues in a minute when our program continues.
博·奥莱利的讲述将在节目继续后的一分钟回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week here on this program we chose a theme. We invite a variety of writers and performance to take a whack at the theme. And today, all of our stories are about friends who get together to try to do some thing and who end up enemies. We return now to Beau O'Reilly's story about his radioactivist friends. As you will recall, they have blockaded a nuclear power plant with results they more or less expected.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在这个节目里，我们都会选择一个主题。我们邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天，我们所有的故事都是关于那些聚在一起试图做某事，最终却反目成仇的朋友们。我们现在回到博·奥莱利关于他那些“放射激进”朋友的故事。正如你所记得的，他们封锁了一座核电站，结果也正如他们所预料的那样。
The initial jailing lasted three or four days, and it was quite frightening for Betty Byzantine. She was with Maggie and Michelle, and both of them remained cool throughout. But that couldn't have helped her. Her fear was now sprinkled with that hot sauce of shame when she judged herself in comparison to them. There were the sounds of beating in adjacent cells and women weeping, and the cell was giddy with disinfectant. It was very frightening for Betty.
最初的监禁持续了三四天，这对贝蒂·拜占庭来说非常可怕。她和玛吉、米歇尔在一起，她们两人全程保持冷静。但这显然对她没有帮助。当她拿自己与她们比较并进行自我审判时，她的恐惧中又掺杂了羞愧的辛辣调味汁。隔壁牢房传来击打声和女人的哭声，牢房里弥漫着消毒水的味道。这对贝蒂来说非常恐怖。
That was probably the first crack in the bond between Betty Byzantine and the rest of us. Because the rest of us delighted in having some of the real dirt of the system under our fingernails. That dirt was everywhere in the county jail. And that same dirt, it made Betty Byzantine shake. And as she was already quivering from the recent coupling of Small Craig and Stalwart Michelle, this trembling had become her way of being.
那大概是贝蒂·拜占庭与我们其他人之间关系破裂的第一道裂痕。因为我们其他人以指甲缝里沾上系统真正的污垢为乐。那种污垢在县监狱里无处不在。而正是同样的污垢，让贝蒂·拜占庭发抖。由于她当时因为小克雷格和忠诚的米歇尔最近的结合而颤抖，这种战栗成了她的常态。
By the time we got to the trial, we were in hippie heaven. And we did wild things there. We read Dr. Seuss books to the jury, and we actually won the judge over and were acquitted. But Betty Byzantine wept on the stand. She snuffled, and she sneezed and spoke in badly formed half sentences, forgetting the judge name.
当我们接受审判时，我们身处嬉皮天堂。我们在那里做了疯狂的事。我们给陪审团读苏斯博士的童书，而且竟然赢得了法官的认可，被判无罪释放。但贝蒂·拜占庭在证人席上哭了。她抽泣着，打着喷嚏，说着不成形的半句话，甚至忘了法官的名字。
The rest of us, we radioactivists rejoiced in our victory. And we came home from the trial prancing and proud and puffed up like David after he delivers that stone onto the head of Goliath. We had an instant reputation amongst the activists for our intensity and our recklessness. And we had two or three, four more actions over the next two years, sticking to the principles of our nonviolence and growing closer and closer to each other.
我们其余的放射激进分子为胜利欢呼雀跃。我们带着胜利从审判回到家，趾高气昂，就像大卫击中歌利亚头颅之后那样自鸣得意。我们在激进分子中因为我们的激烈和鲁莽而瞬间声名大噪。在接下来的两年里，我们又进行了两三次、四次行动，坚持我们的非暴力原则，彼此也越来越亲近。
Probably I never loved anyone as cleanly and without qualm as I loved those radioactivists. All except Betty Byzantine. She loved only Small Craig, and she clung to him like a burr to a blanket, standing off to one side and offering her opinions when asked. And helped when needed, but never initiating anything. Always just there. Her eyes were hooded and secretive as she watched Small Craig and Stalwart Michelle boastful in their pink love haze. They of course were oblivious to Betty Byzantine's painful observation role.
我大概从未如此纯粹且毫无顾虑地爱过任何人，就像我爱那些放射激进分子一样。除了贝蒂·拜占庭。她只爱小克雷格，像刺一样粘着他不放，站在一旁，被问到时才发表意见。需要时提供帮助，但从不主动发起任何事。总是仅仅在那儿。她看着小克雷格和忠诚的米歇尔在粉红色的爱之雾中炫耀时，眼神是阴沉而隐秘的。他们当然没意识到贝蒂·拜占庭那痛苦的观察者角色。
But I wasn't oblivious to it. I could have acted on it. I would have too, except this coldness I felt for her. I was aware of her tension and her fear, and I could have helped her. I could have helped her vent her emotions. I could have suggested kindly that she take a sabbatical. And with any of the others in the group, I would've done that. I saw Betty Byzantine's hurt, but I didn't follow my own rules and reach out to her.
但我并非没意识到。我本可以采取行动。我本也会这样做的，除了我当时对她感到的那种冷漠。我察觉到了她的紧张和恐惧，我本可以帮助她。我本可以好心地建议她休息一段时间。如果是团队里的其他人，我会这么做的。我看到了贝蒂·拜占庭的痛苦，但我没有遵循我自己的准则去向她伸出援手。
We were in our most active period, driving every weekend to trials, actions, conferences, speaking up and speaking out, often driving hundreds of miles a day and sleeping in a pile on someone's floor or couch. It was fun, but it necessitated very close quarters. And Michelle and Craig's affair intensified and deepened. And they pooled their monies together, and they bought a double sleeping bag so as to have some pretense of privacy when we all collapsed at the end of the day.
那是我们最活跃的时期，每个周末都驱车前往参加审判、行动、会议，大声疾呼，常常一天要开几百英里车，睡在某人的地板或沙发上一大堆人挤在一起。这很有趣，但需要非常紧密的空间。米歇尔和克雷格的恋情加剧并深化了。他们筹钱买了一个双人睡袋，好在一天结束时大家都倒下时，假装有一点隐私。
And Betty Byzantine watched like a hawk in those minutes before we all bedded down, and she grabbed whatever strip of floor or carpet that remained next to the sprawling double Michelle-Craig sleeping bag body, no matter how humble or pathetic it might seem. And in the dark, she would sniffle herself awake, her nostrils hungry after the lovers' pheromones, her ears struck wide by the sounds of skin against skin.
在大家就寝前的那几分钟里，贝蒂·拜占庭像老鹰一样盯着，她强占了紧挨着那张米歇尔和克雷格双人睡袋旁剩下的任何一片地板或地毯，不管那看起来多么卑微或可怜。在黑暗中，她会抽泣着醒来，她的鼻孔渴望着恋人们的信息素，她的耳朵被皮肤摩擦的声音刺激得大张。
In the meantime, nuclear power plants still belched and threatened all mankind. And the anti-nuclear movement grew larger and clumsier and more strident. We began to argue with increasing force about what steps to take next.
与此同时，核电站仍然在排放废气并威胁着全人类。反核运动变得越来越大、越来越笨拙、也越来越尖锐。我们开始以越来越强的力度争论下一步该采取什么措施。
We were small and able to act cleanly and without compromise, and that seemed great compared to the bloating anti-nuclear organizations that were growing like mushrooms around us. We needed to be what? More forceful, more aggressive, more knowledgeable? More compassionate? More Marxist? More what?
我们规模小，能够干净利落、毫不妥协地行动，与我们周围像蘑菇一样生长起来的臃肿的反核组织相比，这似乎很棒。我们需要什么？更强有力，更具侵略性，知识更丰富？更有同情心？更马克思主义？更什么？
And finally, one night after a long demonstration where we'd been very much in the forefront and there was lots of press and lots of passion, I was sitting up late with Small Craig and Mordecai and Teddy having one in an endless series of dynamic discussions, how the grouped worked and how the group didn't work. And we all agreed that the group needed a renewal of focus. And what was keeping us from getting that new focus? After all, we were all deeply committed to each other. We loved each other. Distraction. And what was the distraction? There was a short list of possibilities. Political rhetoric, day jobs, marijuana, love affairs outside the group, love affairs within the group, Betty Byzantine.
最后，在一个长时间的示威活动后的一晚，我们当时处于最前线，有很多媒体关注，充满热情，我正和被窝里的小克雷格、莫迪凯、泰迪坐在一起，进行着没完没了的动态讨论，关于团队是如何运作的，又有哪些地方运作不灵。我们都同意团队需要重新聚焦。是什么阻碍了我们获得这种新焦点？毕竟，我们都深深地致力于彼此。我们爱彼此。是分心。分心是什么？可能性名单很短：政治辞令、日常工作、大麻、组外恋情、组内恋情、贝蒂·拜占庭。
Betty Byzantine, like a huge crack in your favorite coffee cup. Once it's there you can't ignore it. I don't want to be in a group with Betty Byzantine, one of us said. But what a shudder of relief we all felt when we heard it. None of us wanted to be in a group with Betty Byzantine, and we would simply tell her that.
贝蒂·拜占庭，就像你最喜欢的咖啡杯上的一道裂痕。一旦它存在，你就无法忽视它。“我不想和一个有贝蒂·拜占庭的团队在一起，”我们其中一个人说。当我们听到这句话时，我们感到了一种多么如释重负的战栗。我们中没人想和贝蒂·拜占庭在一个团队里，我们要简单地告诉她。
And meeting after meeting went by, with the four of us telling Betty Byzantine. Now in retrospect, this seems outrageous, I guess, that we would spend months stuck on this one thing and unable to get through it. But in those days, that was how we did things, our group process, how we talked. That was our strength. That was the subject of endless fascination to us. It was what really interested us-- group consensus. And group consensus insisted on Betty Byzantine acknowledging our rejection and agreeing, consenting. And she would not.
会议一次又一次地召开，我们四个人不断地告诉贝蒂·拜占庭。现在回想起来，我们居然花了好几个月的时间纠结于这一件事，却无法解决它，这似乎很离谱。但在那个年代，这就是我们做事的方式，我们的团队流程，我们交流的方式。那是我们的力量所在。那是令我们着迷的主题。那才是我们真正感兴趣的东西——团队共识。而团队共识坚持要求贝蒂·拜占庭承认我们的拒绝并表示同意。但她不肯。
I mean, Betty Byzantine would state flatly that she had no intention of leaving this group. Maggie and Michelle at first listened. They played it neutral, trying to be helpful to both sides of the disagreement. But slowly, this began to shift.
我是说，贝蒂·拜占庭会直截了当地声明她无意离开这个团队。玛吉和米歇尔起初听着。她们保持中立，试图对争论的双方都有所帮助。但慢慢地，情况开始转变。
Betty Byzantine did not wish to leave the group, and she should not be forced to leave, they argued. Our process was more crucial. It was more actively nonviolent. How we got to our decision, that was the important thing. That was much more important than the decision. Maggie and Michelle called for a decision, an agreement in our argument that would include Betty Byzantine.
她们争辩说，贝蒂·拜占庭不想离开团队，她也不应该被强迫离开。我们的程序更关键。它更积极地非暴力。我们如何做出决定，那才是重要的事情。那比决定本身重要得多。玛吉和米歇尔呼吁做出一个决定，一个在我们争论中能包含贝蒂·拜占庭的共识。
But Betty Byzantine grew flatter meeting after meeting. And the men, they grew hotter and harsher.
但贝蒂·拜占庭在一次又一次的会议中变得愈发冷淡。而男人们变得更加激烈和严苛。
Betty Byzantine needed extra help. She needed extra attention. She was not strong enough. These were our surface reasons for not wanting to work with her. But these declarations of candor, this need to tell the truth under fire, it took on a life of its own. And all four of us felt compelled to just tell all and hold nothing back.
贝蒂·拜占庭需要额外的帮助。她需要额外的关注。她不够强大。这些是我们不想和她一起工作的表面原因。但这些坦诚的宣言，这种在压力下说真话的需求，演变成了一种自我驱动的生命。我们四个人都感到被迫全盘托出，毫无保留。
Betty Byzantine was not charismatic. That was a problem. Betty Byzantine was not essential. She was not cool enough. She was not attractive. Betty Byzantine was a drag. And Betty Byzantine hunched her shoulders and she quivered and she stuck to her guns. She took it. But she would not leave this anti-nuclear family.
贝蒂·拜占庭没有魅力。那是个问题。贝蒂·拜占庭不是必不可少的。她不够酷。她没有吸引力。贝蒂·拜占庭是个累赘。而贝蒂·拜占庭耸起肩膀，颤抖着，坚持自己的立场。她承受着一切。但她就是不离开这个反核家庭。
And then finally, one night, I'd had it, and I just said it coldly and flatly. You know, you have to leave the group for the sake of the group. And if you don't, the group will cease to exist. And I will not agree to continue on like this.
最后，在一个晚上，我受够了，于是我冷冷地、干脆地说：“你知道，为了团队，你必须离开。如果你不离开，这个团队将不复存在。而我不会同意继续这样下去。”
And Betty Byzantine said, no, she would not leave. And in that moment, the group ended. And the look on Betty's face, and the other women, and maybe on all of our faces, was a look of horror that it had gotten so hard and harsh between us all.
贝蒂·拜占庭说，不，她不会离开。那一刻，团队解散了。贝蒂脸上的表情，其他女性脸上的表情，或许我们所有人脸上的表情，都是一种恐惧，恐惧我们之间竟然变得如此僵硬和尖刻。
And the door slammed. It just slammed shut that night. And we'd failed to reach an agreement, and there would be no unanimous revelation. We ended as an activist group, and most of our friendships just sort of blew away. Maggie and Michelle left the community. Betty Byzantine surprised us all then by deepening her activism, becoming a major organizer in the women's movement. And ironically, the rest of us just drifted from activism. Betty Byzantine really showed us all.
门关上了。那天晚上，它重重地关上了。我们没能达成共识，也就没有所谓一致的启示。我们作为激进团体的身份终结了，我们大部分的友谊也随之消散。玛吉和米歇尔离开了社区。贝蒂·拜占庭出人意料地加深了她的激进立场，成了妇女运动的主要组织者。讽刺的是，我们其余人反而远离了激进活动。贝蒂·拜占庭确实让我们所有人都刮目相看。
So today when I saw her at the mall and she gave me that long, cold finger, I could see that she had progressed. She was no longer hunched and quivering. Betty Byzantine seemed to be doing just fine.
所以今天当我在商场看到她，她对我竖起那根长长、冰冷的中指时，我看出她进步了。她不再弓着身子颤抖。贝蒂·拜占庭似乎过得挺好。
[MUSIC- "WE SHALL NOT BE MOVED" BY PETE SEEGER]
[音乐 - 皮特·西格的《我们不会动摇》]
Act Three, Racial Factions.
第三幕，种族派系。
People do things in a group that they would never do one-on-one. For yet another example of that, we turn now to Glenn Loury.
人们在群体中做的事情是他们单独一人时绝不会做的。为了另一个例子，我们现在转向格伦·劳里。
Glenn Loury's on the list, whenever anybody makes a list these days, of the preeminent black intellectuals in this country. Formerly a professor at Harvard, now at Boston University. His writing appears in a variety of scholarly and popular publications, including the Wall Street Journal , The New Republic , and many, many conservative journals of opinion.
如今，每当有人列名单时，格伦·劳里都在其中，他是这个国家杰出的黑人知识分子之一。他曾是哈佛大学教授，现在波士顿大学任教。他的文章发表在各种学术和大众出版物上，包括《华尔街日报》、《新共和》以及许多许多保守派意见期刊。
In the prologue to his book, One by One from the Inside Out, a book of essays on race and responsibility, as it says on the cover, Loury tells the story of an incident that happened to him in the 1960s on the south side of Chicago where he grew up.
在他那本关于种族与责任的论文集《从内到外逐一分析》的序言中，劳里讲述了20世纪60年代他成长过程中的芝加哥南区发生在他身上的一件事。
He was at a black political rally, the exact nature of which he writes he does not remember. His best friend, Woody Jordan, brought him.
他当时在参加一场黑人政治集会，他写道他不记得具体性质了。他最好的朋友伍迪·乔丹带他去的。
Woody is a guy who looks like a white guy to anybody who didn't know him and who'd be walking by on the street. They would assume that he was white. Anyway, we're at this rally, and Woody wants to say something. And the leaders, these guys in dashikis, the Black Power captains, sort of turn on him sharply, and they sort of say, what are you doing here? How can you have something to say at our rally? That's part of our problem. White people are always peeping our hole card was the phrase that was used, I remember very clearly. But we never can go downtown and find out what the white man is thinking about. And then finally the guy says, who can vouch for this man? And to my everlasting shame, the fact of the matter is, I failed to speak up for my lifelong friend. I failed to vouch for him and to tell them that this guy was OK.
伍迪是个在不认识他的人看来像个白人的人，走在街上，别人会以为他是白人。总之，我们在集会上，伍迪想说点什么。那些领导者，那些穿着长袍、黑人力量组织的队长们，突然严厉地转向他，质问他在这里做什么。你凭什么在我们的集会上发言？这是我们问题的一部分。当时很流行的一句话是：“白人总是窥视我们的底牌。”我记得很清楚。但我当时从没去过市中心，不知道白人在想什么。最后那个人说：“谁能为这个人担保？”而令我终身羞愧的是，事实是我没能为我终生的朋友挺身而出。我没有为他担保，也没有告诉他们这家伙没问题。
I was intimidated by these guys and perhaps insecure in my own authenticity as a black person. And I abandoned my friend in order to not offend the sensibilities of people who were essentially strangers.
我被这些人吓倒了，或许对自己作为黑人的真实性缺乏安全感。我抛弃了我的朋友，只是为了不触怒那些本质上是陌生人的敏感神经。
Can I ask you, at one point in the essay you write, "I would always be black in white America, yet my standing among other blacks could be made conditional upon my fidelity to the prevailing party line of the moment." I wonder, do you see part of this as the nature just of any group, any religious, or political, or social group, that as soon as it begins to define itself as a group, inevitably it begins to define who is in and who is out? Who is really in and who is really out?
我可以问你吗？你在文章中写道：“在白人统治的美国，我永远是黑人，但我与其他黑人的地位可能取决于我对当时主流党派路线的忠诚度。”我想知道，你是否认为这不仅是任何群体、任何宗教、政治或社会团体的本质，即一旦它开始定义自己为一个群体，就不可避免地开始定义谁在圈内、谁在圈外？谁是真正的圈内人，谁又是真正的圈外人？
Well, yes, I suppose that's so. Although, as I say, I would always be black in white America. That is, there's a sense in which for African Americans, to a certain degree, those boundaries are given in the situation. And we then add to them by, as I say, constructing these tests of what it means to be genuinely or really black. Black people are not supposed to be interested in classical music. They're not supposed to be interested in the German language. We're not supposed to like Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young, and so on.
嗯，是的，我想是这样。虽然正如我所说，在白人统治的美国，我永远是黑人。也就是说，在某种程度上，对于非裔美国人来说，这些界限是既定的。然后，正如我所说，我们通过构建这些关于什么是“真正”或“正宗”黑人的测试来增加它们。黑人不应该对古典音乐感兴趣。他们不应该对德语感兴趣。我们不应该喜欢克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯、纳什和扬等等。
Glenn Loury says in his essay that after that rally, he and Woody never discussed the incident. And while they continued to be friends for a while, things were never the same between them.
格伦·劳里在他的文章中说，那次集会之后，他和伍迪从未讨论过这件事。虽然他们又做了一段时间的朋友，但他们之间的一切再也回不到从前了。
When I called Woody Jordan to get his side of the story, he had not spoken to Glenn Loury in years. He didn't know that his former best friend had written any books, much less any that mentioned him.
当我打电话给伍迪·乔丹寻求他的故事版本时，他已经多年没和格伦·劳里说过话了。他不知道他曾经最好的朋友写过任何书，更不知道书中提到过他。
Jordan still lives in Chicago, is an attorney in the Public Defender's Office on the murder task force. He has a caseload of 25 adults and juveniles, all of them accused of homicide. The largest thing on the wall behind his desk at work is a poster, put out by the Black Panthers. "Eldridge Cleaver for President," it says, with the word "revolution" twice in huge block letters. And though his old friend Glenn Loury doesn't remember what rally it was a quarter century ago, Woody Jordan remembers. He says it was a Black Panther rally immediately after police killed panther leader Fred Hampton in his bed in the middle of the night in Chicago.
乔丹仍然住在芝加哥，是公设辩护人办公室谋杀案专案组的一名律师。他有25名成人和少年被告的案件，所有人都被控犯有杀人罪。他办公桌后面的墙上贴着一张最大的海报，是黑豹党印发的。“埃尔德里奇·克利弗竞选总统”，上面写着，巨大的块状字母写着两次“革命”。虽然他的老朋友格伦·劳里不记得四分之一个世纪前的集会是什么集会，但伍迪·乔丹记得。他说那是黑豹党在警方深夜在芝加哥床上杀害黑豹党领袖弗雷德·汉普顿之后立即举行的集会。
The evidence showed that there were 72 rounds fired from outside of the apartment. Man, this gets me mad just talking about it. There were 72 rounds fired into the apartment. And maybe, maybe, one round fired out.
证据显示，公寓外开了72枪。天哪，光是谈论这件事就让我愤怒。向公寓里开了72枪。而外面，可能，可能，只开了一枪。
But while he remembers the politics of the rally and the details of the murder, he had completely forgotten the incident that Glenn Loury describes in his essay. He said this kind of challenge about his blackness happened to him all the time when he was a kid. On the street, at parties, at school, from cops. And he was surprised that his friend found any reason to write about the rally at all.
但虽然他记得集会的政治细节和谋杀的经过，但他完全忘记了格伦·劳里在文中描述的那件事。他说这种对自己黑人身份的质疑他在小时候经常遇到。在街上、聚会上、学校里、警察那里。他很惊讶他的朋友竟然会觉得这件事有什么可写的。
It didn't bother me any more than to the end of the day. You know, I never said anything about it because it wasn't any big thing. Obviously, it was a big thing for him. And if it was, he should have said something by now, doggone it. But by then, my emotional callouses were quite thick. That particular incident, I had honestly forgotten about it because it had happened so often before. It didn't stick in my mind that much.
这对我来说没造成什么影响。你知道，我从没提起过，因为那不是什么大事。显然，对他来说这是件大事。如果真是那样，该死的，他早该说出来了。但到那时，我的情感茧壳已经很厚了。那件事，我诚实地说，我已经忘了，因为以前经常发生。它没在我的脑海里留下太深的印记。
Let me ask you what you make of this sentence from Glenn Loury's writing. He says, "Upon reflection, my refusal to stand up to Woody exposed the tenuous quality of my own personal sense of racial authenticity. The fact is I willingly betrayed someone I had known for a decade, a person whom I loved and who loved me, in order to avoid the risk of being rejected by strangers.
请允许我问你对格伦·劳里写的这句话有什么看法。他说：“回想起来，我拒绝为伍迪挺身而出，暴露了我对自己种族真实感的不确定性。事实是我为了避免被陌生人拒绝的风险，自愿背叛了一个我认识了十年的人，一个我爱他、他也爱我的人。”
I had feared that to proclaim before the black radicals in the audience that this white boy at my side was in fact our brother would have compromised my own chance of being received among them as a genuine colleague."
“我曾担心，如果我在台下的黑人激进分子面前宣称，我身边的这个白人男孩实际上是我们的兄弟，会损害我被他们作为真正同事接纳的机会。”
Let me ask you, what do you think of that? What's your reaction?
让我问你，你觉得呢？你有什么反应？
I can take it two ways. I can take it one, as just being-- I mean, you got to remember. He's talking about a time when he was still a freaking kid. OK, that's one way of looking at it. The other way of looking at it is, let us assume that this is an adolescent who was, in fact, in possession of all of the faculties of an adult male, of a grown man. Maybe what was going through his mind is, what's more important, one individual or my people? Unity or one individual? And how do you answer that? How do you answer that?
我可以从两个角度看。第一，那只是……我是说，你得记住。他谈论的是他还是个孩子的时候。好吧，这是一种看待方式。另一种方式是，假设这是一个具备了成年男子所有官能的少年，一个成熟的男人。也许他当时脑子里想的是：什么是更重要的，一个人还是我的人民？团结还是个人？你该怎么回答这个问题？你该怎么回答？
I think that in the final analysis when you're talking about a situation where you feel that your people's survival is actually threatened, then your people are more important than one individual.
我认为归根结底，当你谈论一个你觉得你的人民的生存确实受到威胁的情况时，你的人民比一个人更重要。
But if you follow that argument to its logical conclusion, then you're saying that he would have been right to turn his back on you in that crowd if the situation were dire enough.
但如果你把这个逻辑推到极致，你就是在说，如果情况足够糟糕，他在那个人群中背对你也是对的。
I'm not so sure it wasn't. I'm not so sure it wasn't.
我不确定当时情况是否没那么糟糕。我不确定它是否没那么糟糕。
But he would be right at your expense and at the expense of your friendship.
但他会以牺牲你和你们的友谊为代价来证明自己是正确的。
What's more important, your people or one individual? I'm just one person. I'm not that important. Maybe what he did was the right thing. Maybe what he did was right. The issue is unity, not friendship at that point.
什么是更重要的，你的人民还是一个人？我只是一个人。我没那么重要。也许他做的是对的。也许他做的是对的。问题是团结，而不是那个时候的友谊。
Oh, that's fascinating. He certainly has got the spirit of the moment just right because the issue was unity. And I wish it were true. I wish it were the case that my motives had been that pure, that I had said, ah, the right thing to do here at some level is to defend Woody, but that would disrupt the unity of this meeting. But you see, that wasn't my thinking. I mean, I was not a politician. I was an 18-year-old kid. I was somebody who was overwhelmed by the more immediate and visceral feelings of acceptance and embarrassment and insecurity. The only unity that I was interested in was the unanimity of that group in thinking that I was a good guy. You know what I'm saying? Not black people forever and we got to stick together to fight the man. It was just merely, please don't look askance at Glenn.
噢，太令人着迷了。他确实抓住了那一刻的精神，因为问题确实是团结。我希望这是真的。我希望我的动机真的那么纯粹，我也希望我当时说过，啊，在某种程度上这里正确的做法是捍卫伍迪，但这会破坏会议的团结。但你看，那不是我的想法。我的意思是，我不是政治家。我当时是个18岁的孩子。我是一个被接受感、尴尬感和不安全感这些更直接、更直观的情绪淹没的人。我感兴趣的唯一“团结”就是那个群体一致认为我是个好人。你懂我的意思吗？不是黑人永远团结一致对抗当权者。仅仅是，请别用那种眼神看格伦。
One of the odd things about this story is that it's Woody who takes you to the rally, and then it's him who ends up having to leave in shame.
这个故事奇怪的一点是，伍迪带你去参加集会，最后反而是他落得个羞耻离开的下场。
Yeah, and Woody is the guy who's working as a public defender defending black and Hispanic, I'm sure almost entirely, people accused of murder. And I'm the guy who people call a black neoconservative whose daughter, ironically, is an assistant district attorney in Chicago at this very moment.
是的，而且伍迪是那种在公设辩护人办公室工作，替黑人和拉美裔——我肯定几乎全是——被控谋杀的人辩护的家伙。而我呢，是人们口中的“黑人新保守派”，讽刺的是，我的女儿现在正是芝加哥的一名助理地方检察官。
Really? So your daughter could be prosecuting cases that he's defending?
真的吗？所以你的女儿可能正在起诉他辩护的案件？
She prosecutes juvenile felons, some of whom are up for murder. I don't know if his practice includes the public defender of juvenile defendants. But in theory, yes.
她起诉少年重罪犯，其中一些面临谋杀指控。我不知道他的业务是否包括少年被告的公设辩护。但理论上，是的。
I think you guys should sell the movie rights to this to somebody. I don't know exactly who. There's some made-for-TV movie in here somewhere. I don't know what.
我觉得你们应该把电影版权卖给谁。我不知道确切卖给谁。这故事里藏着一部电视电影。我不知道是什么。
You know, yeah, that's an idea. But it abounds in ironies, that's for sure.
你知道，是的，这是个主意。但这充满了讽刺，那是肯定的。
I should tell you that in his office he sits-- the largest thing in his office right behind him when you come in and see him is, there's an Eldridge Cleaver poster.
我得告诉你，在他的办公室里，他坐着……当你走进去看他时，他办公桌后面最大的东西是一张埃尔德里奇·克利弗的海报。
Get out of here.
滚开，别骗我了。
No, for real.
不，是真的。
That's unbelievable. ,
真不可思议。
Unbelievable in what way?
不可思议在哪方面？
Well, you know, the last time I read Soul on Ice it almost made me want to throw up. I mean, Eldridge Cleaver of 1968, yeah. Eldridge Cleaver looked at now with 28 years hindsight, my god.
嗯，你知道，我上次读《冰中灵魂》时差点想吐。我是说，1968年的埃尔德里奇·克利弗，是的。以28年后的眼光回头看埃尔德里奇·克利弗，天哪。
What's on the walls of your office right now?
你办公室的墙上现在挂着什么？
Photographs of me in the company of Ronald Reagan on one occasion and Margaret Thatcher on another, among many other things. But let me just duly note that those things are there.
我和罗纳德·里根在一起的照片，还有和玛格丽特·撒切尔在一起的照片，等等很多东西。但我得如实说明，那些东西确实在那里。
Well, our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Dolores Wilber, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt and Margy Rochlin. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
今天我们的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我本人制作，多洛雷斯·威尔伯、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与制作。编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any other of our programs, visit our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can also to listen to our programs for free.
如果你想购买这期或其他节目的磁带，请访问我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，你也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes his management style this way.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他这样描述自己的管理风格。
Well, I'm either completely nuts or right on target, one or the other. And there isn't anything in between.
嗯，我要么是彻底疯了，要么就是正中目标，两者必居其一。除此之外没有任何中间地带。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。